los diputados a la asamblea nacional
francesa debaten tres mociones de
censura contra la primera ministra
Elizabeth Bond dos tienen como punto de
mira la ley del presupuesto del Estado
para 2023 y son presentadas por la
alianza de izquierda nups y el partido
de extrema derecha reagrupación nacional
respectivamente y una tercera cuestión
al presupuesto de seguridad social
iniciativa de la propia nubes los textos
pretenden forzar la dimisión de la líder
del gobierno que deberá responder a
ellas también este lunes desde el propio
hemiciclo el Palacio Borbón aquí a mis
espaldas la maniobra es una especie de
castigo contra La Premier luego de que
ella aprobara ambos textos
unilateralmente al invocar el artículo
49 inciso 3 de la Constitución ese
apartado le otorga al ejecutivo
precisamente el derecho de validar sin
votación un proyecto de ley y enviarlo
al senado la sorpresa de este lunes ha
sido ese anuncio de lepen de que suban
cada apoyará el texto de sus colegas de
izquierda algo lo que se mantenía
opuesta rotundamente hasta hace unas
horas posibilidades de éxito de esta
iniciativa muy remotas aún uniendo sus
fuerzas la nupes y reagrupación nacional
no han logrado sumar otras agrupaciones
políticas opositoras en cualquier
escenario quedan muy lejos de los 289
votos que necesitan en la práctica todo
indica que Elizabeth 2 no sobrevivirá a
esas mociones de censura y conservará su
puesto al menos por ahora